Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Outlast 2. Now we just
got escaped from Marta because
"got escaped" is the correct vernacular for this particular
situation. And we're heading up to the mines
to finally--
*Mark is interrupted by Blake *
Again, I was just about to say that! You don't need
to take my thunder from me. You just need to run away like a little bitch
and trust ME not to get YOU killed.
So now that we got that out of the way...
we can finally make our way down into the mines here,
and I can scream my head off at more death coming straight at my face.
Because the heret - oh fucking cacti.
Fuck you! Fuuuuck you!
FAHK you!!
fucking cactuses. All up in my business!
I've got Marta threatening to chop off my junk,
and you threaten to stub my toe! I don't like none of it.
Hello?
"Dearest Marta--" Ohh! A nice one.
*reading the letter*
Well isn't this guy just delightful!
Mmm all this positive reinforcement across his WHOLE congregation!
Just a bunch of rainbows, and sunshine, and murder...
and blood, and death, and ohhh I can't
go up here.
Grrreat. Why did I come here in the first place?
Is that the entrance to the mines?
I mean, it's gotta be right?
I'm not missing something, am I?
Hullooh! Salvation, please!
Ahhh, I see you! I see ye!
I see ye!
Ahh, okay. Ooo. WOAH!!
WHYYYY?!
Oh, so she DID kill herself. Or, quote, unquote, "killed herself".
Yeah, you might want to wake up.
Oh, boy. Yeah, I'm still here alright.
Yeah, I don't know where HERE is, exactly.
NOPE. Ooo fuck, hi. Hello.
Alright, down the dark hallway we go.
Am I going to get any words of positive reinforcement on this venture?
Or am I just on my own? *lockers bang, Mark gets spooked*
Hiiiii
Fuck you!
I was just about to make fun of the darkness!
Usually, that's my only weapon against this horrible monstrosity.
Okaay...
*whispers* what the fuck?
Was that footsteps behind me, or was that just, my imagination?
Eugh.
I remember when there was a game that did that.
It put footsteps IMMEDIATELY behind me.
OoookaAY EEE OKAY!!
Ooooohhhh...
Oh.
Oh wo-!
*bird mating noises*
I don't know if that's important when I'm in nightmare land.
I think that, maybe, I should go back to reality!
That might be a good idea, but-oohhhhh
boiiiiii. Oh boi
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy
Okie dokie then.
Why is the world shimmying and shaking so much?
Oh boy, okay, I'll replace it, I'll replace it, okay.
Kerchunkels. I got the most battery inefficient lights in the entire world!
Okay, so there's got to be something else here.
That I can find.
Another hang-man puzzle because that's what I need to do with my spare time...
Mmkay, hello?
Oh, this is where I came from, can I go through this way then?
Yup, okay. Two halves of a whole idiot here.
Hello ah
Good.
I was hoping
To go in here
I was hoping and praying!
*quietly* 'Kay
So they went to some sort of religious school
So that must be where all this started, I guess
Eugh.
What are you talking about? Who's saying that?
Who's saying these things? This is obviously very glowy
so I need to look at this
OH!
AH!
Unforgivable!
Ah. Okay.  Well, now I got that.
So I guess I need to uh - oh hi. Didn't expect that to open.
What is that? Oh. It's just a shadow. I thought it was like looked like a fetus.
Okay. Got what I need!
Gotta complete this puzzle.
OUH...
I gotta complete this puzzle!
That's what I wanna do with my time...
*mutters* complete puzzles in my nightmares...
My favorite thing to do...
This is the wrong classroom.
Oh good. Thank you for that.
Okay.
Alright. So what I gotta do is I gotta move that thing, I know that...
Yeah okay. Yep.
Yeah why not? Let's make this line up! 'Cause that's cool...
Alright. Put transparency. Hubbaty boop boop.
♪ Unfooorgivaaable ♪
♪ tha-that's what you are.♪
Oh I gotta
*mocking* argh, they're aren't lined up
Super important.  SUPER IMPORTANT!
Uh huh.  I know.
Yeah. I know. Okay. At least this guy is as uh...
Sarcastic as I am... *sigh*
Okay, so what'd that do for me? Huh?
What did that DO exactly?
Why did I bother with that?
Why did I bother?!
What was the point of all that?
Why did I do that??
Can I go now? Oh I can go now.
Oh boy. Oh. Oh...
*grunting/groaning in fear*
You better not.
If you-OOOOOHH. Fuck you if you do this!
If you do WHAT I THINK YOU'RE ABOUT TO DO!
Oh God Oh God Oh God Okay. Alright. OKAY!
What the fuck is that?
OKAY. What the fuck?!
What the fuck was that?!
Hello? Oh... Stop that!
*Cavemen sounds*
Oh BOY!! Fuck you.
Fuck you with that shit. *another caveman sound*
Okay...
AAAAHHH!!! FFFUCKING!!
*squeaks* Yeah okay!
Yeah okay. I was ready for that...
I'd say I was ready for that... I didn't deserve it.
But I was ready.
*gagging/groaning noises*
Ok. Stop whining.
Start surviving. *mumbles* What do we got there?
What's on the screen?
AH! Man. It really doesn't make these interactibles very obvious.
Well, I guess that's good.
I mean real things don't glow in the dark.
Might as well just make em glow I guess.
Oh good! I'm Gordon Freeman again.
Crawlin' through the vents. Yah.
Back here the vents.
What?! No you weren't!!
*cavemen return*
Aw ew gross!
Ooh.
*squeaks*  Whaaat?
Whaaat?
Oh is it almost daybreak?
Oh could it be?!
Oh could it truly be?
Could it really be? Can I get up? *chuckles*
Can you stand up please?
OH. MY. GOD.
Or is it just because the moon is so high?
Oh hi. Ok...
Oh! The bridge!
London bridge is falling down. And I'm gonna die!
WEEEEEE!
Alrighty then.
So ok...
Let's play it then. What I just recorded.
Yeah ok alright then. I get what you're saying. I get what you're saying!
I-woooo I shouldn't jump down there.
That'd be bad-a. That would be a dumb way to die.
I'm gonna go for it. Here we go.
K. Now I got multiple options to die down here, but I'm gonna go for it.
Ah. Well...
What was I supposed to do? Didn't seem like there was an option there.
Seemed like the gospel of Knoth just led me astray.
Fhack off.
Oh well. Ok. *laughing* So there had to be a path down.
There had to be a path down there that I did not see... sooo...
Let's-a go again.
This time not dieing.
Weeee!
Ok sooo... Definitely not down that way.
OOOH! I get it. The precipice!
*manly grunt* Good.
What the fuck is going on down there?
Who's down there?
Why are ya moanin'?
uh...
uh......
Someone's havin' a bad time down there...
Someone's havin' a reeeal bad day.
*mumbling*
OOOH!!
I found seecrets.
Also, you are not looking to good...
*reading letter*
Man. That's so crazy.
It's really hard to read when they don't know how to write properly.
Yeah. What are you doin'? You bein' a little bitch baby about this.
It's a video game. You don't need to be so - whoa fuck.
Don't need to be so worried about it.  Ship oo a do ba-ba.
*Weird Mark sounds*
Aw. Euuuuuw..
uuuh
How 'bout you look at the goddang things in front of your goddamn face.
Oh my Good!
Holy Shit!
It's a fucking swarm!
NOOOO.
NOOOO!!!
Pfft. Ah of course...
*sigh/growl*
Why was there a swarm of locusts?
What kind of magical bullshit powers do these people have?
Hello?
Oh. OH. OH!
Oookay... I am upside-down by the way...
Oh. Hi!
Hel-ooh oh...
oooh....
Oook... Whatever you say...
Think we're meeting the next Marta here...
Ugh...
Ok... What do I do about that?
Drop down? Ok I'll do that...
Euuugh
What is that?
Ow also. My whole bones.
They need to stop doing this to me because it's just plain old rude.
OH! It's my camcorder!
Is it brok-tin?
Is it broke? Oh! Apparently not!
Ok then.
Yeah I guess you are.
As if this wasn't already the long way. But ok. Let's go a little bit farther then.
Why the fuck not?
Why the fuck Knoth?
Ok. So we need to make our way around here, but in the darkness is lurking those two.
If you couldn't tell, It was a big ol' guy.
with a little guy riding on his back.
Reminds me of something else I've seen. Something from Mortal Kombat!
The combo there. Ah.
Ooooh...
*dying caveman noises*
I'm one of you!
*dying caveman noises again*
I-We're- We're communicating!
*that caveman is in much pain...*
Oh we're like whales! (or cavemen...)
Ok...
You want me to document your screams and compare them?
Cause I will. I've got nothing better to do.
Not like I'm trying to find my wiiife.
What've we got here?
*reading note*
I'm sure they do. It's love, or death.
The best kind of love in THIS world.
And alas.
I am without love.
Is that someone actually playing the fiddle in these woods?
Cause my orchestra's still following me.
Well thank you for being so loyal, but also go away. You're blowing my cover.
*mumbles* alright.
Where... OH where?
Is that dynamic der-o?
Ya-hey
Can I crawl under here?
HEY!!
Fuck you.
Fuuuck you!
Yeah. Fuck you!
Fuuuuck you!
*stops for sec*
Fuck you asshole.
Think you can spook me?
I'm unspookable.
And also.
I don't know where I'm going apparently...Oh! I gotta crawl through this log.
Oh this is fun!
Oh this is my adventure. Oh this is good.
Oh yeah. Collapse on me. Crush me. Crush me to death I dare ya!
I double dare ya!
Alright fine then.
I mean if a railway is gonna cause me to fall due a locust attack
Which I don't know if that's ever happened in the entire history of me.
I mean it may have, yes, but me, no.
Sickness here?
Nah. Nah I don't think so.
I'm gonna go through the syphilis woods.
That's gonna be super fun.
Oh... What's here? What's here? What do we got?
Oookay alright. I trust you. I trust this. These seem like stable rocks. Habooski.
Ok. What do we got here? This looks ominous...
A canyon from with which we be to die?
Can we get the flood here? We'd get every problem.
Alright.
*reading note*
Okay, Yeah, let's go with that one
Yeah.
You can uhh
You can
PURGE away your syphilis and gonorrhea
That's good to know..uuugh
euuuugh
euGH
eugh
eugH
euGh
A-Yuck!
Hello?
Who are you?
Oh no
Oh no...
Oh no.....
Hellooo?
Hi!
Hello!
Okay!
Okay..
oOOh
bOOIIII, ooh booii
Ohh booiii
oh boi
I don't think I wanna be here *noises of disapproval*
This seems baaaaad
I'll just take this battery that you probably oh so desperately don't need
I'm just gonna carry it for my own purposes here
don't mind me everybody
aaAAAAAYYYY
ffffffff
Groooooooooosssss
Groooooooooooossss!!!!
Am I infected-oOOOh..hi
Okay, Alright then. Okay, Alright then. Okay! Alright!
Ookay can I go in here? Is this something I can do?
..Why would I do that? I don't even know. That's probably a river of piss
Aaand shit and not good for me to go through
If I'm not infected yet
I soon will be.
euuugh
This guy- WHAOH! WHEY! WHOAH
whoah! whoah! what the fuck???
HEY!
HEY! D? D! I AM D:ING
Jesus Christ!
What did I do to you assholes!?
What did I do???
HUH
Fuck
I would've helped ya
*mumbles* oooh fuuck
Why???
Oh, your faith isn't healing you guys...
Ooh, your faith isn't healing ya
Ouhh
*reading poem*
I don't know what that means but I think its la-oUUHHHHHH
Hi....
How ya doiiiiin'
Aaaah! Your lips are gone!
Niiiiiiiice....
Ok I'm gonna go now..!
I don't know how you're still alive but okaaaaay..
GrooOOOOOOOOoosssss
Just gonna carry on my way
*mumbles*
Okay! Don't know what that means but okay!
Hello! Thank you for this.
Gonna take this again!
Just gonna steal from all you assholes cause you don't seem to be bothering anybody
Let alone me.
Okay.
Yeesh, Yeesh-y
yEEesh
Oh! Hello?
Hello??
Oh hi!
*whispers* hello???
Uh Oh
YESH
O-kay!
Alrighty then!
Love???
Squeeze love out of em'???
Why would you do that???
Uh oh. That ain't good, that's a bad sound
I know that sound! That sounds to be bad!
Uh oh, can't go down that way.. can I go up here?
HOPIEDOO
HIBBIDIBIBI
Okay!
Where am I going??
Am I gonna get shot with an arrow???
Seems like that's what Laird want's to do..
So, what's the other guys name???
Can't just be Laird.
Can't be Laird and Baird.
What the fuck was that? Ok..
Alright then
Good thing all this blood is here-
aaAAAAAAYYYY
OOOOW! AGAIN!
With the being punched in the face-edness
I'm sick of it!
I don't wanna be punched in the face no more!
oooh my glasses
Everytime someone punches me in the goddamn face
Everytime!
Every-fricking-time.
Now I'm down here with Laird and Baird
Larry and Barry
Larry!?
Barry!?
uh oh
UH, WEUH.
AAH! *owl noises*
Why??Why??
WohWuh
nOO
NOOO
NOO!!
Ow! Fuck! Ow! What do I do???
I don't know what I was supposed to do..
But I ran towards the arrows which was my first mistake..
I'm a goddamn idiot, that's what I am.
Okay
I was not READY!
You did not say GO-OOH
Ow! Fuck!
Okay, what do I do? what do I do???
Okay.. do you see me???
Okay
I'll try to slip by
I'm not gonna run for it because they got the range on me, that's for damn sure.
Ok.. No, I'm gonna run for it.
'kay c'mon, cmon, go, go, go, GO, GO, GO, GO
Quick!! behind the treeeeeees
He's out of th- OOH, HI!!!
NO
nO
NUH
NU, NO, NO, nonononono
What the fuck! NO!
Go! Just go!!!!
I don't know where I'm going!
I don't know where I'm going!!
I don't know where I'm going!!!
OH BOI, ohboiohboiOHBOI
OH BOI oH bOI oh boiiii
Okay! In here! Good enough!
ooOOOOOH C'MOOON!!!
oh fuck me
OOOW AGAIN!
OW Why and OW and why you do that
Aaah!! I'm fucked.
I'm fucked!
I'm fucked!!
I've been fucked!!!
I am fucked!!!!
Yeeeesh
I don't know where I'm going, I have no god damn idea
This is all woods to me!
Oh god damn it! I circled back!
wuUUHaYY
oh fuck me
so BONED
I'm so royaly BOOOOONED
oh fuck
Oh, geezums!
Miss me! dick...
Whatchu gon' do?
OW! Fuck I was behind a tree!
Fuck you!
Fuck you!!!
Alright, here we go.
Taking- Oh nO, you don't!
OH! OWWWIEEE
Okay, through here..
Oh c'mon!
I'm dead aren't I?
Ow!
Aaaaaaaah, God, whyyyyyyy?
Whyyy ooh booiiii
You just had to puke on me first, didn't ya?
You just had to.
Okay, so the answer is: Don't run.
The answer is just simply, don't run.
That's a bad idea
So don't-oHH NOO
You did it again, you did it again, you di-
Oh fucking god damnit!!!
Okay.
So the answer is simply...
WHY!!!
What?? Who's doing that!?
Who? What? Fuck you!!!
Fuck you asshole!
Oh again with that
Thank you, Thank you for that.
Thank you for making me feel like a incompetent maroOn
Now, I'm gonna try that again and with less death this time.
Man, it is just, non-forgiving on starting me on, exactly right there.
Jesus!
'Course it does!
Gotta be- There's gotta be a place I CAN go, right?
There HAS to be, right???
It wouldn't just l-
OH! Right here! Really?!
God damnit!!!
How did I miss that? How did I miss that??
Go quicker now!!!
OhMyGod. Where am I? Where am I?? Where am- WHY???
What the fuck?
Principal???
Was that you???
*squeak* what???
What???
Jeeess..?
Jeeeessss...??
JeeEEEeesss?
JEEUuuHHEEESSss!
I don't know what's happening, Jess..
Aw, Ow, my braaaain
What is that?
Is that?
fff-uh..fru..friar
*Reading E-mail*
So, I'm assuming that's probably talking about Jessica.
I guess it seems like Jessica didn't have a good upringing...
Whaaoo.. they seem..
..they seem nice
*sighs* Alright, here we go then..Oooh boooooooi
oh boi
Hello..?
Hellooo?
Is there a reason to come in here or was it just gonna be closed off..
..in hoping no one would actually walk in to that hell-hole
uuuuuuugh
A battery..okay.
Take that..
Any other pages-
Stop that.
God! It just wants to dick with me in these memories
'Cause there's gotta be something psychological to all of this and it's tied to that great big shining light..
Because this didn't start until the light hit the helicopter
And made us crash and burn
It was the light that did it first, because helicopters..
Oddly enough
They can land even if the engine goes out. They're supposed to, they're designed that way
They're not designed that if the engine goes out under any sort of failure, it just falls out of the sky.
Oh and this is gonna be good
Okay...
Oh really!? Okay, alright, that's how it's gonna be
Yeah just, th-snuhuh- for some reason this is here
Yeah.
So, there must be something to that light that is psychological
It's not just
Like-like, obviously there is no magic happening here
But there's something psychological
Even in the first Outlast with the, what is it called?
Wall rider.
Wall rider, the inky blackness.
There was a scientific reasoning behind it
So, there must be a scientific REASONING
Behind that white light..
It's not the glory of God, just shining down upon em'
Oh!
Well, there's the place where I just was..
Seems like I'm just wandering the halls of this school..
..endlessly
So, there must've been something else back that way but that's jammed up
*horse noice*
And nothing else was in there...
Maybe through here..?
WOO!
OOOOH, why am I in the bathroom?
I don't like bathrooms in horror games..
Okay...
Gross.. but okay!
Okay? Why was I in here??
Why did I go in here?
Why?
Why??
*deep breath* OOOOUUHHH
Yeah! Record that one!!!
Okay, I saw that!
I saw that!
I saw that! I saw that! I saw that! I saw that! Okay, I saw that!
I saw thaaat!
Oh, did I already go in here I can't even remember anymore
can'tevenremember!!!
Ooooh, there's no extra stuff
There's no garbo
*what do you call this noice?*
BAM!
Okay, not quite..
Fuck..
But there must be something to that
And in a way
Oddly enough..
Oh..
Hi..
Holy shi-
Fucking, what the fuck??
HowdidInot..uh
How did I not notice that???
How did I not notice that? That was like, really infront of my face there..
The fuck???
Oh geez
But oddly enough, it reminds me of..
The Evil Within
Because if you think about it that's kinda
That was kinda the same thing the de-
Oh fuck..
The device!
That went into everybodys minds, it started from a signal that was broadcast
There's something to that. I don't know if- I've like obviously it's not connected,  they're completely different universes
But you know
I can't help but draw the comparison because it is there
You can't deny
that comparison IS there!
Yeah?
You know what I'm sayin'?
And like the constant going for the church
'Cause you were
And wasn't that in-in, The Evil Within? You were going for the church..?
And the church...
Was the source of the signal were that guy
Just the, brain in the jar..
..that he was...
..stayed.
Oh noo
*groaning in disapproval*
Uhh
Oh!
STANGLE
SAINT! ANGLE!
Saint Rangle.
Strangle.
Okay, Alright then
Okay...
I'll be careful..
I'll be as careful as-OOOOH
OOOOkay
Am I in the log I was in???
How am I going through this?
How am I slipping in and out if reality and not dying a-wHOOOAAA..HI
Okay.. Well, I guess I'm here now...
Thanks guys!
Nah, I don't think so. I don't want that to happen
Okay, hi.
Eughhh
Why do you have to be sure?
Why do you have to be sure???
Why??
Wha- nOOo
OUUUHHHHH
WHY
GROSS!
WHY???
What? That doesn't make any sense!
I'm pure... Okay..
OW!
What the fuck does that mean???
Do I need to be reborn??
Do I need that??
No, how about- okay, alright.
Imma put my-
Imma- hububu- put my foot down here!
Imma put my foot- OW
OH AGAAAAAAIN
I have on rule..
..DON'T PUNCH ME IN THE FACE!!!
Oh boy
Why?
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEAAAA
*mumbles* I'm just gonna throw that out there, I think that's a bad idea.
Okay...
They're not listening to me
euh boi, hi.. okay.
Hey big guy
Well, aren't you kind then!
THANK YOU!
Uh-huh, okay, alright then
Salvation after the end..
Okay..???
*dying bird noice*
Again!
Okay, OAUH..alright then.
*grunt of disapproval*
Oh- Why two???
One was enough!
oOOOWIIE
OOow
OW
oW
It was pretty bad!
You gotta admit, it was pretty bad
Pretty bad
WHAS' DIS'?
Uh-huh, okay.
Hand me what?
Uh-huh
Uh-huh?
Oh! Okay!
You're gonna love what I've recorded!
Sure hope my sex-tapes aren't on that...
It's okay man, don't be so down about yourself
Okay, thank you for that..
Ow!!
OWIE!
What is this the end???
What???
uUUUUUUAAHHHhhhhhh
'Kaaaaay
Grrrrrreeeeeaaaaaaaattttttt
Goooooooooooooooood
Grrrrreeeeeaaaaaaattt
I'm DEAD now!
OHKAY???
Oh, wait no.. I'm not dead..okay
That was all just a GOOF!
IT WAS A GOOF N' A GAFF
Not true!
Oh, just rip em' out!
Rip em' out bruh!!
Rip em'!!!!!
*the noise of a stallion*
RIP EM'!!!
WAAAAAAAAAAH
OOOOOOUH
RIP EM' OUT!!!
Fuck, so baller!!!
Euuuuuugh
Yeah, I'm not gonna be able to use my hands again, am I?
Oh boy... Owiiiiiiiiiieeeee
Yeah! OW!
There's the blood around my eyeballs!
Frick dude..
Just frick dude
Juust frick duude
*chuckles* oh fuck
uGH I need to find bandages
OH!
GOD!
NOO!
Yeah, I gotta stop the bleeding- oh, fuck.. where am I???
I couldn't find my way around when I was- when I DIDN'T...
Have this blurred bullshit on me
Okay, there we go
You don't have my camera.. okay, I gotta whole lotta nothin'
So, I gotta stop the bleeding or else I'm gonna die
And then I gotta find my camera
Ooooh fuck...
Hi.
You probably shouldn't notice me...
ouh boy
Well, this seems bad..
Oh!
Uh oh
Uh oh!
Don't point at me!!!
Don't point at me!!!!!
HeyheYhey, just stop that...
Okay, got this!
Wait
No
Hang on...
Yeah! I bet it does!
Can you not talk while you do that because I think they saw you going in to this tent..
Yeah, OH, that'll make it SOO much better!
Oh, Instant hand healing?!
Oh yeah!
Oh that's the good stuff
Yeah, you'll definitely be able to grip things after that
Holy shit
Ohmygod these guys are insane!!!
Guys are out of their gorge!!!
Oh, Okay, I'll climb up there..alright
I'll do that!
Since I can definitely climb with these hands
Oh yeah
THAT works..
Either..
There's a little thing wrong with physics here or this guy is just a solid grade A badass..
Probably...
So what am I gonna do to get my camera back?
oh, shit, hi.
Okay, yeah. HE'S GONE
He's GONE!
HE'S ASCENDED
My god! Unbelieveable!
Why did they stop watching me, huh?
Well, at least they're not watching me!
Oh booy
uuUUUH
We got pukies over here!
Goooooood... I guess..
euuuuuugh
Nobody's out here.. what are you talking about???
Nobody's out here...
Hello! Oh, that's gross!
That's really gross
No! It's not God!!!
Wh- God?!?!
Is God supposed to die..???
Okay.. there's battery
Grab thaaat
More bandages...
Grab thaat.. okay.
I go through here...
Okay.
I though I saw something down there that might've been a way out but I'm not sure..
Does that go anywhere..? No.
Okay.
So, I just gotta make my way in this- OOOOOOOOOOOOOH
NONONONONONONO
NNNNNNnnnnnn
Yeah, you got that way
You got that way buddy-boo!
Okay, alright, screw you!
F- I can't turn around? Really!?
Oh I'm just- Okay, Alright. I-Ju- DON'T MIND ME!
THIS IS THE ASS OF A SYPHILITIC MAN!
Don't.
Fuck you.
Fuck you!
Fuck you! What do I do!?
Well, Fuck you!!!
He just gave me two slaps on the ass and then I fall over dead!?
What the fuck!
You kiddin me?
Bunch o' bullshit on this one. I tried to play the game like I'm supposed to play it
All quiet and cautious-like
And there's just deaaath
AAAAA
Fuck you!
The fuck!?
Okay, alright then, well, why not?
A! A! A!
No, I don't wanna trust in God right now!
I think your God is a little bit MEAN
And antagonistic towards me!
Yeah you just...
..fall over and die please.
Okay, is he coming towards me? or ar they just don't go towards me very quickly because I think that's the
Current scenario right now
Yeye yea oh ya who knows. Who knows where i am?
Don't...ok ya, you better go over there.
Ok.. so I can make my way through here.
Go in this building
Close the goddamn door. Lock it!
I'll probably have to go out that same way but at least I can gather the supplies in PEACE
uuuGGHHhh
ugh
God Why???
WHY?
Can I crawl under here?
NOOooo... Yes I cAAAn!
Amazingly, through the river of shit, I can!
Right, here we go!
Oh, looks like the guy on his rampage has been through here...
uUUUHHHhh
*the noise of a horse who has given up*
FWUFF
FWUFFPH
*The horse has regained hope*
Alright, let's get my camera back-ouUUuuh
oOOOuuh nononono
How about you don't do that?
My skull is very not ignorant
uh oh
Oh boy
What? The fuck was that?
Hello??
Hellooo???
'kay
Righty then
AHLRIGHTY THEHN
I guess everythings good..?
oohkay...
K, do i go up here?
Ya.
Ya, ya nonono
nonononono do don't hit me with no arrows
this is peaceful climbing time
you leave me the fuck alone
K, there we go, therewegotherewego. yesyesyesyes BOING
Bada bing bada boom
Oooohoh is the wawa, ah ill go in there. Habloosh!
Ok
*bird noise* That sounds bad!
Ohhh Woah
Nick...So Nick and Laird, Laird and Nick.
Laird n --
Uh oh gotta go
Ooo Boi...God dammit just move on!
Move on man
Did you move on?
oh he did
ooo no he didn't! oh boy
ohboyohboyohboyohboyohboyohboy
oh bobobobobobo bo
bo bobah bah
mamamamamama ma ma madness.
mamamamamama ma ma madness!
ok, that will buy me some time. But not a lot, i gotta find my things.
these band do ges
I don't have my things...OOOU There it is!
Uh un unbelievable quantity I assume.
OooooooooooUhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Ya! I don't know how my camera
was able to do that, I have no idea?...Hmm!
D.N.T.L.T... Uhhhh
Donut!
Lit! ME! GO!
ok...Dont let me go. *mumbles* fine, I get it
I understand
So where the hell am I?
Am I in the cafeteria?
Can I just leave? Is that a thing I can do (you wish mark)
Can I can I just leave, NO of course not! there's nothin I can do. I cant just leave
*BOOM*
AYEEEEE
Great...Thank you for that.
Its if i need higher blood pressure as it is. *grumpy*
PPPPFFFT fun
k, so this is that same hallway, that same thing
I just went up there
Alright so where does this lead?
What kind of horrors, am I about to find?
Ah good yes another paper
More Hangman
Uhh Suffer! the children
OOHKAy
Why?
That doesn't seem like a good thing
OooooohKay
Aaaalllrighty then
Hello again! I'm here....
Oh it's open now!
Haaai Ok why!
OOOOOOH NOOoO
OK!
OOOOOHNOO
Wait! so, I'm recording this!
I AM legitimately recording this!
RIGHT?
I, I'm literally recording this!
Am I not?
No, I'm not!
Cauze it's a banch of garbo
*Funky static*
*More funky static w/ talking*
*Mark lookin like a dipstick*
Ooooooooh ok noonono not again
OoooOh? Oh has there been hiden messages this whole time?
If I've been recording inside my memories
I think maybe yes!?...
I think maybe absolutely, yes!
Which means...
There's something here...
*mumbles* Is that a phone? What? Where? What?
Hello?
Okay.... These are the doors that I've open already!
OOOOOOH HAAAI OHHHHHAI  OHHAI
OHHAI
OHHAI!
OHNOWHYTHEFUCKING
God dammit
OKAY?
WeLL Fuck me then?!?
I didn't know you were a real thing!?
I DIDNTKNOW
WHAT THE FUCK! UHOH UHOH OH GOGOGOGOGO
GOGOGOGO RUUUUN Running now is a good thing!
RUUUUUH
OH BOY
Oh boy Ohboyohboyohboy
WHOA
Okay...
Am I ok?
I can't go out of here
I don't know if I'm ok?
the fuck was that...
The fuck!
Yeesh
Yessheroni
Ohwhoaok... little shimmy a little shammy
awe fuck this the phone again?
you still here?
*Phone rings* You still here? Mr. Hands...?
Uuuh Boi
OK alright! were good now, I guess I'll just answer this.
Sure!...Why not
Wa-Wha?
Uhhhh
EWWWWWWW
What the fuuuck?...
whoa Jesus, dude. Jesus seems to be staring at me.
a lil judgmentaly. but uh...
idk..idk idk idk.At this point I don't know
AYYEUU
Fuck,What happened?Am I going the wrong way?Am I about to die?
I'm about to die aren't I?
ok, alright then, you know what.
AYE OHHHHHHHHH WHOHHHH
GEEEEESH
MMMMRAYYY
Who's coming?
What do I dooo?!
Immna hide!
yes?ok.
Ohhhhhhhhhh *Much relief*
Ahhhh
I'm in a closet...OhKay
I'mma end this one here
Cause... my heart can't take it no more.
This game is awesome and terrifying, and I love it so.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you are enjoying it
And as always I will see you, in the next video..
BUHBYEE!